but you're awfully quiet did you go to
college I did I went to university
Minnesota I didn't finish so I dropped
out to play poker cuz I'm an idiot but I
got a 31 I'm a singer really yeah
to gamble yeah I made like I was living
with college roommates I made like
$40,000 in nine months online but like I
was just smoking a bunch of weed and not
going to class and I dropped out I don't
know if I'd brag I'm not on a CT no
that's one is good thirty one's really
good any 30 or higher it's really good
no it's good 30 I got 30 - you did I
swear on my life or 32 but I'm a CCTV
I'm I'm impressed but I consider that
really good yeah yeah I consider both of
them good huh you can't say 31 you can't
say 31 is bad and 32 is I think yeah
this is some big scores up 34 will get
you into like any place in the 36 as
high as you can get yeah yeah I don't
know if they change cuz they either like
a writing portion and stuff now but how
long does it test I don't know three
four hours or something four hours SAT -
no SAT was big in Denver SAT was bigger
than the a CT cuz if you want to go to
California school you need the SATs yeah
west coast does SATs East Coast as a CT
we didn't have it SATs I don't think
really we had a CTS and we had and the
SATs out of 1600 we had leap leap test
hmm if you want to go to the next break
it - take this hair I don't have that
but then they let mini all em efforts in
the end of the grades bruh
you're letting half y'all on the grades
can't even read freakin half you guys I
think it's your arm painted okay
struggling in class hey Nick dropped out
to be a high school degree then [ __ ]
play some poker bro you tell me man and
then one day you just logged in I'm
already dropped out of school and like
you signed in to the poker sites and the
feds seized everything it's called Black
Friday and poker circles and like you
just couldn't play anymore so then then
I got a job at Sports Authority
super more authority is nice though yeah
also whoa is dart dart dart I think Dart
Sporting Goods and Denver they switched
them yes yeah it started an eagle
Colorado actually good how far were you
into school all the way I have like I
literally like us a little more than a
semester do you ever want to go back
like quavo ah maybe one day but it's
definitely not necessary to anything I'm
doing now how'd you get above producing
podcast I got I was sleeping in my car
and I got an internship at the Adam
Carolla Show I literally moved from
Minneapolis to LA because I thought
podcasts were growing and I wanted to
work for it and I listened to curl every
day listen to you guys I went to you the
first day I was living in my car I went
to a live show of fighter in the kid it
was it was that it was that it was
during the day it was like on a Tuesday
a social media week LA and 2015 yes it
was in Santa Monica yeah I was in the
crowd I wasn't really yeah oh my god
that was our first live show yeah and I
mean it was a because there were like
seven people in the crowd they didn't
know who we were I was like cussing out
there that I can't buddy no and did burn
didn't does Brendan seem any different
now than he did then man uh nah see same
goofy lovable guy you know Nixon that's
gonna pick flannels I can't see Nick and
Hawaii yeah you don't drop out of
college become a professional gambler
and wear Hawaiian shirts going online
yeah you can't make any money real money
in person five tables at a time baby
really mm-hmm
Wow it was honest and that's like when I
started really listening to podcast and
[ __ ] so all things happen for a reason
yeah you're the same thing just because
daddy funded him you know I'm Sam and
what about you Chen how did you end up
in the podcast world um it's a boring
story though not really it's kind of a
dope story well I was doing I was a
producer in a voiceover
director for a Spanish dubbed Korean
television show it was a kpop show so I
actually directed people voiceover
director to people in Spanish oh wow
[Laughter]
nice interacting people directing hold
network's acting people know they're
actually they're actually Spanish
speakers but they're dubbing / Korean
television show pop joke did they have
to speak English also and you told that
you you translated the korean to english
and just told them in english no so we
had to translate do the entire sheet and
then i would just direct him how to say
it just like to voice act it was just
voice acting I said but then I did that
and I rented my own studio so I built
the whole studio there - mm-hmm
and I rented that on the weekends my own
with my own money and produced podcast
just to learn it and then Brennan and
finally kid Brendan was on Joe Rogan's
podcast
they're looking for a producer and I
just randomly thought I'm gonna see him
at a show
give him a thumb drive with all my
information on it
all the shows I did all stuff he took it
reached that later boom would you do
with the thumb drive I did a set at the
Laugh Factory so what five years ago -
four four four I was doing said The
Laugh Factory I got stage and chit was
like I'm your next producer samurai
sword he was a badass thanks dude
and this has actually haunted me for
years he came in to Corolla because he's
friends with Chris Locke samana who's
Adam Carolla's producer and I worked
there at the time and he came in just
like asking questions how they ran stuff
and he left and I wanted to apply I was
not qualified at the time for like run a
podcast but I literally I go to Chris I
go I hope he doesn't get it
literally felt I live like that was just
bad juju you got a room for people I
feel bad 195 no match to you wishing the
darkness on people then there brother
I'm glad I got it off my chest alright
look what you have now I do I do
hope he doesn't get it
you're like everything's my pouch where
do I start
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]